marine biologist Andre Gaia chant his
research team are gearing up for their
next dive they make dives like this only
half a dozen times a year
so they're truly special opportunities
expeditions are something that I
consider as a personal thing we usually
plan every dive in a minute we plan
every every activity every species that
we want to see a film to take samples to
analyze they've come to observe the
shark and Ray populations which have
seen an 85 percent decline in the region
what they're learning is disturbing
samples we catch transponders caused off
around this part of the Adriatic Sea and
we cut all the organs and we didn't
believe to find anything suspicious but
they were they were all sick and that
was extremely surprising not only for us
but for all other colleagues our own all
around the world was now cooperating
with us and that was not only surprising
but it make us very worried on an
ordinary dive they descend about 50
meters there's been relatively little
research on the sea life here and
virtually no other Studies on diseases
affecting creatures like the leopard
shark or the shortfin mako shark
this is part of the pathological
collection at the University of Sarajevo
scientists here study fish such as rays
or skates which end up as bycatch in
fishing nets
the researchers x-ray them take CT scans
and study tissue samples under the
microscope one image shows a healthy
shark liver another an unhealthy fatty
liver it is normal to have up to 50
percent of the fat within the liver and
what surprises more so that they have
far more than the 50% and beside that
you can see the how the micro vesicles
actually destroy the cell they've also
found hepatitis and degenerative tissue
changes around 90 percent of the tissue
samples showed evidence of disease the
researchers have yet to uncover the
cause Andre Gide says it could take up
to a decade to identify the
environmental factors that contribute to
these diseases
of the books on the islands
to do this they'll need to
systematically study sharks and
stingrays along the entire adriatic
coast including Croatia and Montenegro
and rigorous research and environmental
NGO shark lab Adria also includes
technicians and students today they're
out studying sharks I started with shark
lab about a year and a half ago I've
been on three expeditions so far and
have really learned a lot they're
planning to take another dive this
evening we need to dive during the night
because during the night we can find
more rays after several hours they find
a number of these marbled electric rays
it's population has also declined
dramatically the town of Nome is on the
adriatic coast
it's a popular holiday destination for
bosnia and herzegovina all of the town's
sewage flows directly into the sea some
of it unfiltered
the wastewater that we need to deal with
and there is also there's also need for
better low regulations which will help
us to maintain our weight one cause for
the decline of some species is
overfishing the biologists see
sustainable fish farms as a possible
solution this one is owned by even komak
his family fished here for generations
until open water caches declined our
forefathers fished but it was different
then they fished for themselves and even
they didn't have enough to supply the
market that's why we've started these
fish farms today we can supply all of
Bosnia and Herzegovina with fish the
findings of andhra gaia CH and his team
have raised international concern now
gaya CH hopes to open an ocean research
institute in his home country and he
hopes that one day biodiversity will
return to the Adriatic so that it'll be
as rich in species as this Marine
Aquarium
[Applause]
you